RFK Jr as predicted over the past couple
of days announces he is running not as a
Democrat for president anymore but as an
independent we have to acknowledge the
truth we do face a decaying
infrastructure and record record levels
of suicide depression addiction chronic
disease we do face an entrenched
political corruption and an inequality
of wealth not seen in a century but the
good news is that people like yourself
are finally fed
up
something something is stirring in us
that says it doesn't have to be this way
and that's why I'm here today I'm here
to declare myself an independent
candidate he is an independent candidate
for president and he's got doesn't seem
like a huge crowd there but a crowd
enough at least for the announcement uh
this is a smart move for Bobby Kennedy
Jr he was obviously not going to win the
Democrat nomination he's polling at 15%
among Democrats that's not enough to get
you there even if it were enough the
Democrat Party still has enough control
over its process that it
can at least to some degree overrule the
voters it wasn't going to happen so now
he runs as an independent some
conservatives are worried I'm not
worried Bobby Kennedy I think takes more
votes many more votes away from Joe
Biden than he does from Donald Trump
some right wiers kind of like Bobby
Kennedy because he was against the coid
vaccine that's pretty much the only
reason for conservatives to support
Bobby Kennedy he's pro-abortion he's
anti-gun he's pro-immigration he's he's
a liberal he's a he's a liberal Democrat
on basically every single issue except
for coid vaccines he's he's fanatic
about global warming I don't think he's
a terrible guy he's a much better
Democrat than most Democrats out there
but he's going to appeal to moderate
Democrats he's not going to appeal
mostly to conservatives center right
magga Republicans any of that I am all
for the Bobby Kennedy independent run I
do not think he is going to be Ross
perau I think he is going to be Ralph
nater and I am here for it we need some
renewal in our political order and you
need renewal in your home which is why
you got to check out Renewal by Anderson
right now text nolles to 2300 for most
homeowners window replacement is not
something they've done before for many
others it is not something want to do
but rather something they have to do
have you put off replacing the windows
in your home because it's too expensive
well I've got great news you can now get
a free inhome window consultation and a
free quote from Renewal by Anderson
Renewal by Anderson's signature service
is committed to giving you the best
customer experience possible supported
by the best people in the industry right
now Renewal by Anderson is offering a
free inhome or virtual consultation UND
durable quality affordable windows or
patio doors for $ Zar down zero payments
and zero interest for for one year text
nolles kwes to 200 300 for your free
consultation save 375 bucks off every
window and 750 bucks off every door
these savings will not last long so be
sure to check it out I had a carpenter
write to me totally unsolicited said
when he goes into homes the best work he
sees is from Renewal by Anderson text
nolles kW to 2300 that is nolles to 2300
texting privacy policy in terms of
conditions posted at text plan. us
texting enrolls for recurring automated
text marketing messages messaging. May
apply reply stop to opt out go to
windowappointment now.com for full offer
details gen Z is drinking a lot less
than other Generations I was just on
vacation sipping a few salty dogs by by
the pool you know not being very much
like a Zoomer according to this report
from the journal nearly a quarter of 18
to 29 year olds are more likely to smoke
cannabis compared to older Generations
that to me should be the headline of
this article because the headline of the
article and the whole thrust of it is
genz they're sober they're not drinking
the Millennials and the Gen xers and the
Boomers they're they're alcoholics but
the younger generation is getting sober
they're not getting sober they're just
getting intoxicated on other substances
and the substance they're getting
intoxicated on is marijuana which uh
older Generations are much less likely
to use and booze is better than pot is
what I'm saying I know this is going to
be controversial I know my chat is going
to explode with a bunch of people who
have Grateful Dead playing in the
background who are you know just kind of
vibing out to the show and they're going
to say Michael how dare you say that
marijuana is a miracle drug it cures
everything every problem I ever had was
cured by marijuana I love it it's great
booze is terrible the minute you take
one smell of a glass of wine you're
going to just start going out and
beating your wife and neighbors and dogs
and shooting people and you don't and
you're going to hear all of this but
it's simply not the case uh Tucker
Carlson had a good argument on this not
that long ago
Tucker said that this was back when he
was still on Fox the ruling class they
want us to to put down
tobacco and pick up marijuana so it's
not about lung Health it's not about our
alveoli it's not about cancer risk or
anything like that it's simply about one
smoking substance over another tobacco
for all
its negative side effects it makes you
sharper makes you faster makes you more
focused it's the sort of thing you do
while you're working so you can work
faster and harder it's the sort of thing
that the manly men in in Mad Men were
doing marijuana Makes You duller Makes
You stupider makes you slower makes you
less funny makes you less ambitious
makes you want to eat more potato chips
okay so the regime they don't care about
your lungs they don't care about your
health they just want you complacent and
stupid I think the same thing applies
here I'm not recommending that anyone
drink to excess ever but alcohol makes
you a little more sociable alcohol makes
you a little more chatty at parties
alcohol livens you up it's a social
lubricant marijuana does the opposite
marijuana makes you more introverted
makes you kind of sit around pull back
into yourself makes you slower makes you
so if you got to pick one don't do
anything to excess but that's I don't I
do I know all the all the JZ all the
establishment Outlets they're probably
going to view this as a good thing I
don't view it as a good thing you have a
choice between a nice glass of red wine
and a
bong civilization chooses the red wine
boy what a great clip that was
now you got to ring that Bell subscribe
to the Michael nlls Show YouTube channel
we'll see you next time